si lanzas tres monedas cuál es la
probabilidad de que obtengas al menos
dos cruces el diagrama de árbol de abajo
nos muestra todos los posibles
resultados de lanzar tres monedas aquí
en la cima del árbol tenemos las dos
opciones para el primer lanzamiento
después a partir de eso para él para el
segundo lanzamiento puede caer ya sea en
caras o cruz si cada cruz en la primera
puede también caer en cara o cruz en la
segunda y para el resultado de la
tercera moneda también tenemos estas
posibles opciones
así que pensemos en cómo podemos
representar obtener al menos dos cruces
o cuáles son todos los posibles
resultados que nos restrinjan a obtener
dos cruces entonces este nodo aquí nos
dice que estamos obteniendo cara en la
tercera moneda cara en la segunda moneda
y cara en la primera moneda cierto
obtenemos aquí tres caras entonces este
no cumple lo que estamos pidiendo ahora
en este otro nodo aquí tenemos cara
tenemos cara a cara y una cruz al final
cierto cara cara y cruz pero solamente
tenemos una cruz
necesitamos al menos dos ahora este nodo
aquí tenemos cara a cruz cara solamente
es una cruz entonces no nos sirve en
este otro tenemos cara cruz cruz así que
este si está cumpliendo lo voy a
colorear este si cumple lo que estamos
pidiendo tenemos aquí al menos dos
cruces cierto ahora aquí tenemos cruz
cara cara que nos sirve cierto ese nos
sirve
aquí tenemos cruz cara cruz así que este
si cumple lo voy a colorear ahí está
luego tenemos cruz cruz y como tenemos
dos cruces aquí cualquiera de estas dos
opciones funciona ajá entonces aquí
estas dos opciones funcionan tendríamos
cruz cruz cara y cruz cruz cruz entonces
regresando la pregunta si lanzas tres
monedas cuál es la probabilidad de que
obtengas al menos dos cruces bueno aquí
en los resultados podemos ver que hay 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 posibles resultados de
monedas justas y de los cuales
tenemos 12 344 de estos cumplen lo
requerido así que 4 sobre 8 es igual a
un medio la probabilidad de que obtengas
al menos dos cruces es igual a un medio